よろしくお願いします
あの今日決められているテーマっていうのは
あの悟りというものは何ですか？というテーマでございます
で この悟りという言葉は
まあ日本語の言葉で それに合う何か仏教の言葉があるかないか
ちょっと考えてはみましたけど
で あ まあ日本語の悟りっていうのはあまり一般的な言葉で
で 仏教の中では 特にお釈迦様の教えの中では
それはとても大変難しい専門用語なんです
で 説法の中でも全くほとんど説法できないテーマも
このそのテーマなんです
ですから まあほとんど喋れないんですね
もう喋れないんです そういうことで
まああまり立ち触ろうとしないテーマなんです
どうかわかりませんだけど
まあ何か全く理解不可能ですよと言ったら
それにそれで喋りなさいと言われる傾向がありますけど
それなんか まあどういう心理かはあまりわかりませんですけど
で まあとにかく一般的な皆様方に役に立つようなところで話をさせていただきます
あの経典における またお釈迦様
我々目指しなさいと言っている
その超越した真理に際してついて語ることはできるだけ避けときます
で えっと まあ悟りという言葉はないんだけど
お釈迦様は我々に一般的な日本語で言えば悟りましたという言葉を言うんです
で そのお釈迦様は自分が悟ったということはどういう言葉で表現しましたかというと
パンニャーウドパーディ
その言葉パンニャーっていうのは智慧のこと
ウドパーディっていうのは現れましたと
智慧が現れましたと で
またもう一つ言葉ありまして
ヴィッジャーウドパーディ
ヴィッジャーっていうのはもうサンスクリット語
パーリ語だったら結構違う言葉なんですけど
それもまあ智慧のことなんですね
元は同じなんです パンニャーといえば知ることで
ヴィッジャーと言っても知ることなんです
ですからパンニャーウドパーディ
ヴィッジャーウドパーディ
で あの どうやって区別するかというと
まず全く区別はないんです
パンニャーとヴィッジャー
でも働きとして見ると
まあパンニャーというのはまあ知ることなんですね
ですから まあ一般的に知ることで
ヴィッジャーという場合は
まあほんのちょっと使い方が変わっているところもあります
何かを知る だから何かを知るために
その何者か知るものをどんどんどんどん研究したり
探検したりしなくちゃいけないんですね
それで我々は何かを調べて探して研究していったところで
そのものについてノウハウというか
知識が自分に得られるんですね
そこで全部わかってしまったところで
その場合はヴィッジャーというんですね
わかりましたと 例えば何かを問題が起きたところで
そこをどういうことかと調べたくなりますね
知りたく調べたくなったということは知りたくなります
そこで調べて研究して
研究していろんなものを情報やらいろんな立場で探して探し求めたところで
あ こういうことでしたんですかと
最終的には自分に自動的に答え
結論が出てくる その方向でだいたいヴィッジャーという言葉を使っているんですね
ですから 現代勉強にもその言葉を当てはめるんです
パンニャーはあまり当てはめないです
ですから インドの世界で
インド文化圏では何か
例えば学問を励んでいる人は
ある特定の学問 それをずっと勉強して研究して
最終的に一人前になったならば
その学問について彼はヴィッジャーというものは持っているんだと
というふうにこの使うんです
ですから 今も私たちの国でも同じであるし
インドでもどこでも同じであるし
この学校という場合も
このヴィッジャーという言葉を使ってヴィッジャーがある場所とか言うんです
サンスクリット語だったらヴィディヤーレ
ヴィディヤーヴィディヤーレアンというんですね
パーリ語だったらヴィッジャーなんですけど
サンスクリット語の場合はヴィッディアなんです
で それで学校だったらこっち
これこれに LとYをつければ学校なんです
カレッジなんです そうやってこの言葉の意味を理解していただきたいんです
だからパンニャーというパンニャーレというのにサンスクリット語の言葉がないんです
作る作れるんです パンニャーがある場所ということで
阿頼耶という言葉をつけちゃえばパンニャーレ
でも全然そういう言葉がないんです
ヴィディヤーレという言葉はあります
辞書を引けば見つかるんです
学校という意味なんですね
そこでこの博士とか あるいはこの博士っていうのは
もう大学でもらうちょっとした修了証明書なんですけど
そうではなくて いろんな分野で優れている研究成果を出している人々にも
大体名誉としていろいろ学位なんかに与えれるくれる場合がありますね
その場合も パンニャーという言葉は全然使わないんです
ヴィディヤという言葉を使います
ヴィディヤパティとかヴィディヤ
ブーシュナ ヴィッダラ
ヴィッダージョーティとか
いろんなもう名誉敬語ですか
いろいろあります そこでパンジャーとヴィッジャーが何が違いますかね
で ヴィッジャーの場合は
自分で努力して やがて目が覚めて覚めましたというふうな意味なんですね
で パンジャーという場合は
なかなかこのそうやってこの定義でもって
あのデリミテーションというか
このあのガイドラインを作ることはちょっと難しいんです
時々 この人間に基本的に必要なものはパンジャー
その場合もあります あなたにヴィッジャーできないのはパンジャーがないんだから
と我々も使うでしょう
あんた頭が悪いんだから勉強できませんと
そこでその人は反論すれば
勉強すれば頭が良くなるでしょうと
という反論もできますけど
勉強すれば頭が良くなりますけど
あなた頭が悪いんだから勉強できないんだと
ということも言えるでしょう
そのどんな差がありますかね
その言葉の中で あなたは頭が悪いんだから勉強できませんと
逆の反論で勉強すれば頭が良くなるでしょう
とまあ 頭が良くなります
勉強すれば でもあなたは頭が悪いんだから勉強できませんと
その区別 いくらかお分かりになるだろうと思います
やっぱりどんなものでも勉強しようと頑張っても
何か本来何か能力が必要なんですね
この本来持っている能力
生まれつき その 例えば勉強できる人にとっては
もうほとんどのことを勉強できるでしょう
いわゆるやろうとすればできるんですね
時々 頭のいいいい子供たちっていうのは
自分の学問を決める時はすごく悩んだりするんですね
あれも勉強したいし これも勉強したいし
これも勉強したいんだと
でも これに決めちゃったら
あれ全部やめなくちゃいけないんだから
なんかどうしようかなと
でもそれやりたいんだけど
やっぱりこれもやりたいんだと
そうやって悩んだりするのは基本的に頭がいいんです
ですから やればあれもできて
これもできて これもできるんだと
という状態なんですね
ですから 人間に基本的にあってほしいものみたいな意味でパンヤーという言葉を使っているんですね
そこでパンヤーあるんだったら勉強できて
勉強したところでまたパンヤーが現れることということになっちゃうんです
いわゆる頭が良ければ勉強できますと
すごいずいぶん勉強して優れた勉強をしたならば
ものすごく頭がいいんだと言うんですね
ですから 頭がもともと良くても
勉強してなかったならば
あの人は何も勉強してないんだということになってしまっちゃうんで
何も知りませんと 賢そうに見えるんだけど
全然ダメですよと 何も一つも勉強してないんだと
役に立ちませんということにもなります
ですから これ 仏教の話ではなくて
一般的な言葉の話なんです
一般的な言葉でいうと
パンヤーとヴィッジャーの間ではそういうニュアンスがあるんです
だから学校にパンヤーレイとは言わないんです
そう言ったら サンスクリット語から考えればおかしいんです
ヴィディヤーレと言うんです
ヴィディヤーレというのは学ぶところですから
そうやって なんかもうあってもなくてもどうでもいいニュアンスの差があるんです
パンヤーとヴィッジャーの場合は
これ日本語でどう言えばいいかと
もう私は日本人ではありませんので
日本語の言葉はそんなに明確に分析することはできません
私はほんのちょっとしか単語を知りませんので
だいたい日本語で言えばパンヤーも知恵でヴィッジャーも知恵なんです
そこであの 日本語だったらこの知識智恵という 2つの言葉がありますね
でもこの漢字で見ると漢字で見ると何が違いますか？と別に大した差がないんですね
知識だから知る心ですからね
知られる能力ですから
知識でしょうし 知恵と言ったっても別に知恵ですからね
それは差がないんですけどね
その差ですか この知識
まあパーリ語 サンスクリット語であっても大体同じなんです
学んで得る知識もどこかで智慧と引っかかっていると
ですから 普通の世の中のことを学んだりすると
経済学でもあるし 地理学でもいいし
何でもいいんです それはとことん勉強していくと
なんかどこかで人格もそれなりに一人前になってくるんじゃないかと
ですから どんな分野であろうか
専門家になってくると
プロになってくると いくらか人格としてもあの人できているということはあるんですね
その場合は 知識と知恵がどこかでつながっている
関係ある それからお釈迦様が悟ったというところで
パンニャーも現れましたと
ヴィッジャーも現れましたとおっしゃっているんです
まあほとんど同義語なんですけど
いわゆるパンニャーっていうものは完成しましたと現れましたと
ヴィッジャーというものは完成しましたと現れましたと
ですから どう言えばいいんですかね
とにかくお釈迦様は修行して
修行の結果として その後でおっしゃった言葉だから
ヴィッジャーという言葉は使えるんですね
よく頑張ったんだから
よく頑張って修了しましたと
それだったらヴィッジャーという言葉を当てはめるんですね
そこで勉強すれば頭が良くなるという結果だから
パンジャブでパンニャーも現れましたと
ということを使ってます
同義語なんですね それから文学的にこういう言葉も使っています
あの子でばいい あの子っていうのは光なんです
光が現れましたと それはこの光が現れたという意味ではありません
そこはちょっと文学用語なんですね
それはこの暗闇に対して
暗黒状態に対して 光 暗黒状態というのは何も知らない
見えない世界で そこに光が現れたら
もう何でも明確に見えるんですね
そんなような心の中で変化が起きるんです
暗黒状態でいる人類がある修行によって
ある実践によって 突然もう光の状態に変えて変えてしまっちゃうんです
自分の精神は暗闇の中にあるんだけど
ある日突然光の状態になると
それを暗闇と光の区別で
暗黒状態ではもう何があるかさっぱりわからない
仮定するしか推測するしかできません
暗闇の中で何か触って
これはおそらくこういうものではないかと推測することしかできません
でも そこに光があるんだったら
推測は要りませんね あ
ここにこういうこういうものがありますよと一遍に見えるんですね
そこで暗闇の中で物事を推測する場合は
一つ一つ触ってみて 押してみて
匂いを嗅いでみて いろいろなことをして
あ こうではないかと でも確かじゃないんですね
それで次の品物に行って
それ触ってみて 押してみて
匂いを嗅いでみて あーおそらくこういうものではないかと
でもどこかで納得いってないんですね
あの 確定していないんですね
そこで次の品物に行かなくちゃいけないでしょ
暗闇の中にいる場合は
そうやってその人は 暗闇
ものすごい暗闇の中にいる人は
そうやって一つ触ってみて
それで何かをあの一時的な結論を出して
推測を出して 推論をして
こうではなかろうかと
次のものを触ってみて
それにも一応推論を出して
こうではないかと こうですということではないんです
で 次の品物に行くと そうやって今まで出した推論はまた並び替えたりして
その上さらに推論したりする働きが世の中にあるんですね
そこでその人がその自分いる場所の中にある品物を全部というのおかしいんだけど
一つ終わったら次のもの
それ終わったら次のもの触ったりする
でもその人に一度でも
あ 私はこの場所にあるすべてのものを把握しましたということは言えないんです
またあるかもしれませんだから
だから不安定な状態でずっといるんです
この例え すごくいい例えなんです
すごくよく考えてください
私たちはかなり大きな部屋で
大きなホールの中で 真っ暗で
またいろんなものがあるところで中に入れちゃって
かすかな光もないんだと
蛍１匹ぐらいの光もないんだと
それだったら この部屋の中で
この建物の中で何があるかとハッキリ言いなさいと言われたところで
死ぬまでやっても一つもはっきり知らないんですね
それから終わったんですか？って聞かれてもわかりませんと
もっとあるかもしれませんと
そこでまた前触って触れて結論を出したものも
暗闇だから知らなくて
また同じものを触って
あ もう一つあるんだけど
これもなんとかなんとかって言うかもしれませんね
そういう心の状態 それは人類のみんなにあるんです
その暗闇の中で知識を探している状態
そこで光が現れたら このホールがいくら大きくたっても
パッと光が現れたりする
それで全部いっぺんに見えちゃうんですね
だから歩き回らなくたってば
一箇所に止まって紙 1枚持ってリストすることもできますね
こちらで席はこれぐらいありますと
椅子はこれぐらいありますとかね
カーテンはこの色ですよとか
それ全部終わったところで終わります
終わりましたよと 堂々といるんです
終わりましたと ですから
この悟りについても お釈迦様はそのたとえでアルコウドパーディという言葉を使っているんです
それで差がわかりますかね
この反対の言葉も使っているんです
暗闇が破れましたと タモパーダーリトというパーリ語なんですけど
暗闇が破れましたと アルコウドパーディ光が現れましたと
これですから 悟りっていうのはなんかそんなもんなんです
光が現れることなんです
光が現れたらもう落ち着きます
もう全部いっぺんに見える
見えると知られると そこを私たちはどのように理解しますかというと
私たちは 一般的な生き方をしている我々は
いつでもなんかこの不安定な状態
心にありますね ずっと
本当に自分が物事を知ってますかと正直に自分に聞くと
やっぱり知らないんですね
例えば学校の先生がいるとする
その学校の先生にあんたは結構教えているんだから
もう教師として完璧だと自信持てますかと
絶対その自信は持てません
死ぬまで もう教師として私はもう全て知ってるんだと
という状況には絶対ならないんです
例えば 経済学者のノーベル賞でも取っている人がいるとします
そこで あなたは経済学問の世界で全て知り尽くしたんですかと
自信ありますか？と言えば
はっきり出てくる答えは全く自信がないんだと
ほとんど知りませんと
ですから そういうことなんですね
我々の心の働きっていうのは
やってはいるんだけど
全く自信がない お医者さんにしたっても
一応治療はしているんだけど
まあたまに聞いてみて下さい
この病院に行った時は
先生にこういうこういう患者さんのこの病気について確実に治してあげられると
確実にこの病気の原因とか
それをはっきり知ることはできるという自信がありますかと
聞いたら 正直な先生だったら全く自信はありません
この薬が効くか効かないかとか
自信はないんだと というはずなんです
そういうことで 私たちの生き方っていうのは
いつでも勉強はする いろんなものを苦労して知ろう知ろうと努力する
それなりにまあいろんなことを知ってもいる
でも あの暗闇の暗い部屋の中に光が現れたような感じで
ああ 知りましたよということにはならないんですね
その心の不安をなくす方法なんですね
悟りっていうのは そこでこの心の根本的な問題解決します
だから 例えば完全たる医学者にするかというと
そうするんじゃないんです
根本的な問題 例えば人がなんで医学やりますかと
なんでやりたがってるんですかと
そこら辺 心に不安があるんです
3人の若い人を選んだら
一人が医学を選ぶかもしれません
一人は工学を選ぶかもしれません
一人が文化系の文学を選ぶんだと
こう  3人とも死ぬまで研究したっても
不安で死んじゃうんですね
全然知りませんという状態で死んじゃうんですね
そこで 3人とも基本的に
基本的な心の問題があるんですね
なんで知りたがるんですかと
そういう基本的な心のこの働きを明確にして
安定感 安心感を作ると
すごいしっかりすると
そうやってお釈迦様は自分でそれを体験したんですね
一人の人間として もう知りたいものは山ほどあるし
ああいうことで だからといって納得いかないし
疑問っていうのはもう無数に限りなくあるし
答えを探さなくちゃいけないし
一つの疑問に答えが見つかったら
また次の疑問がそこにあるし
そこで何か答えが見つかっても
どうもなんかもうちょっといいものがないかという気持ちなんですね
我々は生きている上ではいろんな疑問に答えが見つかるんだけど
これは答えですよというしっかりした答えではなくて
まあとりあえずこういう答えなんですけど
もう他のいい答えがあればいいなという気持ちもありますね
そうやって この心のこのすごいこの不安定な状態があって
そこで修行の結果として
お釈迦様はものすごい心の安定感
安心感を感じてしまったんですね
そういうことで アーローコウウデーパーディと
もう光が現れましたと
ということで 悟りという仏教でいう境地を説明しているんです
その説明で なんとなくいくらか何かお分かりになるでしょうと思います
心は安定するんです そこで他の経典の中でいろいろ違う言葉で同じことをおっしゃるんです
疑いは晴れましたと という言葉があるんです
それは このティンがビチキッチャーという言葉なんですけど
ビチキッチャーっていうのは疑いやいろんな疑ですね
疑問ですね そういうのはティンっていうのはもう乗り越えたと
疑いの海を渡りましたというふうな意味なんですね
疑いってどんなことですかね
いつでも我々の心にあるんです
その疑いっていう精神的な状態
本当ですか？と 何だろうかと
そうかなと ああだこうだという気持ちで
心の中でずっと疑いという不安定な状態働いています
その疑という海を乗り越えたと
渡りましたと もう一つ
悟りのことを説明するもう一つの言葉があります
アカタンカタという まああのちょっと言葉ちょっと変えましたけどね
あの経典に出てくる方法もちょっと変えて書きましたけど
アカタンカタという言葉はだいたいあるんです
アカタンカタっていうのは
やめた方がいいね いろんなところでいろんな意味で使ってるんだから
ちょっと説明混乱します
カタンカテーティンナーイシキッチョウカタン
か スペリングはちょっとスペリングによって意味が変わりますから
ちょっと自信はないんだけど
私は言いたい意味はそういう意味の言葉がありますけど
そうではないか ああではないか
おそらくこうではないかと
もしかするとこうではないかというふうに
この心の中にある このもやもや状態
こうではないか ああではないかね
おそらくこうだろうとかね
そのもやもや状態 この不安定な状態がもうなくなってしまったと
そのそのような言葉が
このアーロークウドバーディという言葉からも理解できます
暗闇に光が現れたら もう何があるかとも知ってるんだから
もう疑いは消えちゃうんでしょうし
ですから 違う言葉でお釈迦様が疑いが晴れますか？晴れました
心のもやもや状態 こうではないか
ああではないかという状態はもう消えましたと
そこでものを知りたがっている人々が
暗闇で触って暗闇で触っているんだから
終わりないでしょ 暗いホールの中で
いくら触って触って触っていっても
もう本当にわからないんですね
何が全部何があるかと
まだありますかと どこに何がありますか？そこをそれほどわかるわけじゃない
それでもものすごい丁寧に真剣に考えて考えて
触って触っていくと いくらかはまあこんな感じではないかという知識が現れますけど
それでもしっかりはしません
ですから 暗い暗い部屋の中にいる人にとっては
いつでも頭の中にある感情が
もっと知らなくちゃいけないことはあるんだと
あるかもしれませんと
知ったものも全部完璧に知ったわけじゃないんだと
ですから また仕事を残っているんだという感覚がいつでもあるんです
これ 例えで考えてみてください
すごい大きな暗い部屋に人を入れちゃって
この部屋にある品物は全部調べてくださいと
全て言っても それはその人の仕事だから
その人は一つ一つ一つ一つ
根気よく丁寧に触っていくかもしれませんだけど
いくら触っていったっても
仕事を終わりましたという気持ちにはならないんです
見たんですか？でももう 3時間ぐらい見たんだけど
終わったんですか？それはわかりませんと
もっとあるかもしれませんと
あるいはもっとありますよと
そういう気持ちになるんです
ですから 暗闇の中にいる人にとっては
永久的に仕事は終わらないんですね
やり残しあるんです そこは人生に入れ替えてみてください
人生の中で私たちには
どのように頑張っても
何をしたってもまだあるんです
やり残し まだやっておかなくてはいけないものはまだまだたくさんあるんです
そういう誰かがいるんですけど
私はもう全部仕事を完了しましたと
人間としてやらなくちゃいけないことは
そういう気持ちないでしょう
そこで この暗い部屋の中にいる人に品物を調べなさいと仕事を渡したところで
もしその人が電気のスイッチでも発見して
これ入れたところでパッと光が現れると
そこでその人はいっぺんに全部知って終わって終わりました
仕事を もう調べるものはないんだと言うでしょ
そこで その人の言葉は仕事を終えましたと
そこでお釈迦様も自分の悟りはこういう言葉で説明するんですね
カタンカラニーヤンという言葉を使っているんですね
カタンというのはなすべきもの
ないない すいません カラニーヤンというのはなすべきもの
カタンというのは成し終えた
カラニーヤンというのはなすべきもの
カタンというのは成し終えたと
するべきものは全部し終えたんだと
で それとこのアーロークウパージ
ぴったし合うでしょ 意味は
光が現れたという意味とカタンカラニーヤンという言葉も
ただ言葉を入れ替えているだけ
人生と暗闇にある人生に光が現れたら
もう人生としてやるべきことはすぐいっぺんにしてやってしまって終わっちゃうんです
暗い部屋の中にいる人に必要なのは
品物を調べるんじゃなくて
品物を触ったり押したり
舐めてみたり 嗅いでみたりするんじゃなくて
スイッチを探すことなんです
仕事を置いておいて 電気のスイッチはどこにあるんですか？と
それ見つかって それをスイッチオンしちゃえばもう終わりと
そこで調べる人が部屋に来て
あんた全部見た？で見ましたよと
どれぐらい品物を触ります？ 1つも触ってないんだと
というぐらいも言えます
だから品物を全部触ってみた人が暗闇の中で知りませんでしょ
一つも触らないでずるい人がもう電気スイッチを見つかって電気入れちゃいますから
品物を一つも触ってないんだけど
仕事終わってるんです
そうやって だから仕事を終えましたと
いわゆる仕事でなすべきことを終えましたということで
解脱の境地をカタンからニーヤンという言葉でも使ってるんです
そこでなすべきことを成し成し終えたという場合は
大体お釈迦様は別に何考えてるかというと
この人生というものなんですね
生きるということ 問題なんですね
それについて問題は解決しましたと
その問題は基本なんですね
私たちは生きるということを研究しないで
生きるために必要な道具の研究はしているんです
例えば 医学薬学を勉強するのは何のためですか？と
それは生きるため 起こる問題
何か解決するためでしょうに
農学やるのも同じことで
それは生きるために必要な道具でしょう
生きるために必要な道具
全部揃ったっても もう生きるということを知ったわけにはならないんですね
問題は なんで生きるために道具必要ですかね
なんで医学なしに我々は生きていられないんですか？なんで農業なしに我々は生きていられないんですか？なんで社会学
経済学 政治学などなどなしに生きていられないんですかね
もう違う言葉で言えば
なんで我々は勉強しなきゃ危ないんですかね？なんで我々は結婚しなきゃダメですかね
なんで子供を作らなくちゃいけないんですかね
なんで真剣真面目に社会の平和やら家庭の平和やら
町町内会の平和やら ああだこうだとか苦労しなくちゃいけないんですかね
ですから 私たちにはやらなくちゃいけないことはもうありすぎ
やりきれないんです 家庭は平和で必要だと思っても
仕事はありすぎてできなくなっちゃうんです
子供の面倒は真剣に見るべきです
思ったっても 自分がやることいっぱいあって忙しくてできないんです
そうやって私たちには生きる上ではやらなくちゃいけないことはもうありすぎ
だからどんな仕事も中途半端で
手抜きでいい加減で終わっちゃうんですね
だから一つも納得いかないんですね
子供は育てたんだけど
納得はいかないと 仕事はしたんだけど
納得はいかないと 結婚はしたんだけど
納得はいかないと どんなものについてあっても
その感覚はあるんです
その気持ちは そこで我々仏教でお釈迦様が出す質問は
なんで生きるという この過程の中で
こうやってやらなくちゃいけない問題いっぱい出るんですか？ということは
生きるということ自体が問題でしょうと
それだったら先にそれ勉強しましょうと
それ先に勉強してしまえば
それは基本の土台だから
医学も法学もその上に建てたってるんだから
この土台自体が問題いっぱいだったら
何建ててもガタガタでしょうと
まあ川を渡ろうと海を渡ろうと
我々は船を作ったとする
船を作ったところで まあそれはなんとかして
漕いででも先へ進まなくちゃいけないんだけど
暇がないんだと このボートを漕いで向こう側に行くために
あっちこっちから水漏れるんだとの中で
それもなんとかパッチすると
他のところから出てくるんだと
そうやっていると ここの方にもっとガタると倒れちゃうんだと
そうやってちょっと前にこうしたところで
船が前に行くんじゃなくて
ぐるっと回ったりするんだと
それでなんで回るんですか？ともう調べたところで
船のバランス感覚が悪いんだと
それいろいろ修理したところで
こちらなる板を 向こうに持っていったりとかしてたら
こちらからまた水が漏れ始めると
そうやってもうずっと溺れるまで船の修理するんです
ということは あなたは漕いで向こう側に行こうとするんじゃなくて
先に船の修理しなさいと
船自体が間違っているんだと
そうやって私たちは幸福になろうとして
政治学も法学も医学も何学もいろんなことをやってます
社会学も宗教もなんだかんだも
でも幸福にはなりっこはないでしょう
ということは ライフジビタンです
パーリの言葉は それもお釈迦様は船に例えているんです
ライフという生きるという
この船が なんかおかしいと
そこをなんとかしましょうと
ですから 生きるという問題解決した人にとっては
法学も医学も薬学も何学も何もいらなくなっちゃうんです
もう安定しているんだから
全ていらなくなっちゃうんです
そういうことで このすごい何かすごい深いところなんですね
悟りっていうのは 深いところだけど
仏教ではこれものすごくしっかりしていることで
皆様に悟りはわからないはずなんです
わかると言ったら それはもう嘘です
でも推測はできるはずなんです
だから悟り理解する前に理解しておかなくちゃいけないことは
あなたはどんなものかと
私は何者かということなんです
そこで悟りの推測できます
で 今は今の説明の中でもそこら辺はわかると思いますけど
例えば私たちはずっと精神的になんかどこかで不安を持ってるんですね
いつでも 例えばもうゴルフやっても
これで完璧だという気持ちがないんです
もうちょっと首が曲がるんだったらいいんじゃないかと
もうちょっと姿勢がしっかりするんだったらいいんじゃないかと
もっと違う あれ 何て言いますか
なんか大きな棒 いろいろあるでしょうよね
そういう なんか違う道具があればいいんじゃないかとかね
だからそれは世界この一流の一流ランクのプレーをやっている
もうもう何千万ドルのドルの賞金をもらってやっている人々にしても同じことなんです
勝負で負けるんだから
そういう人々も そういう人々もずっと訓練するんです
だからね 世の中っていうのは不思議でしょう
どこかの学者になりますって
大学のなんかすごい有名な研究所を作って
この研究 何て言いますか
そちらの所長になっていたっても
その先生に聞けば 先生はこの先生の研究分野について完全たる知識を得ているんですかと
はっきり返ってくる答えはないと
ないんだからこそ その先生は死ぬまでか
その研究所から追い出されるところまで研究し続けるでしょ
あんたはもう老いこぼれで
もう何もできませんだから帰ってくださいと言われるところまで
研究者が研究するんです
そこで仕事をクビになったっても
悔しくて家の中でも今までやった研究の論文を読んだり
新しいものを考えたり
書いたりする なんという人生ですかね
これは料理の研究家も同じなんです
どれぐらい新しい料理の発展しても
まだ考えるんです 他の方法はないかと
そうやって私たちは客観的に
具体的に自分という人生を見てほしい
見ると何が見えますかというと
私たちは必死になって走っているんです
いろんな分野で いろんな世界で
いろんなことをしながら走っているんです
どこまで走っていても
走ったという気持ちはあるんだけど
どこへ走ったかわからないんです
だから最後になってくると
なんかすごく納得いかない
お医者さんとしてずっと頑張って
ものすごい一流に頑張っても
走ったことは走ったんだけど
80歳ぐらいになっちゃうと
なんか世の中のことを何も知らないんだと
自分が 仕事一つだけで生きてきて
仕事終わったところで
なんかものすごい惨めになってしまっちゃうんです
だからその人は本気 本気
本気になって 無駄に時間使わないで一生懸命走ってきたんです
人生は 走ってきたんだけど
結局どこまで走ったかということはないんですね
だから 子育てに一生をかける人々も多分同じことで
自分の年も取ってボロボロになるまで一生懸命子供を育てると
それで自分の人生終わってしまったんだけど
それで何か得たんですかと
といったものは何もないんですね
結局は そういうふうな人間の生き方があります
それは全ての人類の生き方なんです
これから逃げようと思ったっても
それはできません じゃあ私はその生き方から逃げますと
できませんよ そんなことは
誰でもそうやって走らなくちゃいけない
で わかりやすく言えば
人を持ってきて 人の目隠しをして
目隠しをして あなたはゴールまで走りなさいと
そこでゴールは見えませんだからゴールはどこにありますか？と
それは前にあるか後ろにあるか私はわかりませんだけど
とにかく走ってみなさいと言ったら
目隠ししている人が前か後ろか
左か右か そっちもわからないんだけど
とにかく走ると 倒れるところまで
走ったところで倒れたところでゴールですか？と
いえ 違いますと もうどうしようもないんだ
人生終わってしまっちゃうんですね
ですから 私たちも必死になって
ダンスの稽古もするわ
水泳の稽古もするわ まあいろいろ勉強もするわ
いろんなことをやってますけど
それで完璧に納得して満足していますかね
心が それによって人生観
人生って何ですか？と
生きるということはどういう意味ですか？と発見していますかね
それは発見しないでしょうね
別に生きてるんだから
あの絵の教室に行っただけのことで
生きていなきゃいけませんだから
だから生きる 生きるということ自体
勉強したことがないんです
それで宗教の世界もと同じで
この商売繁盛できる方法とか
能力開発する方法とか
超能力現れる方法とか
いろんなものを売り物に出してるんだけど
あれもあんな変なことで生きるために必要なものであって
生きるということの勉強ではありません
この必死になって走っている人々が
もう簡単便利でたくさん儲かる方法がありますよと聞いたら
そっちのほうに行きたくなります
そんな方法はないんだけど
やっぱり宗教というのは信仰の世界だから
そういうものは売ってるんですね
信仰というのは証拠はいらないという意味ですから
保証は要りません ただ売るだけ
これ買ってくださいと
買ったら良くなりますか？という保証はありません
保証はありませんと という感じで信仰を売ったりするし
で ですから そうやってこの現世利益やら御利益やらいろんなことをめがけて信仰を走って信仰に走っていっても
生きるということはどういうものかという
このすごい哲学的な質問には答えが出てこないんです
だからずっとどこかで不安残っています
そこで その不安 もしさっと消えたならば
それは悟りなんです その心の疑いが消えたならば
それは悟りなんです ですから
この悟りを得た人が いかなる生命の中でも究極的に落ち着いているんです
そこでわかるんです 悟っているかないかと
なんか不思議に落ち着いているんです
心の中 だから知り終えたんだから
これ 例えで言いましょう
例えば お父さんが自分の息子さんに自転車に乗る
乗れる 乗ることを指導しているんだと
小さな自転車買ってあげて
じゃあ教えてあげますからと公園に連れて行って乗せてあげて
あ こうではない ああではないとかね
ちょっとちょっと待って
まあこうこうやってバランス取ってくださいとかね
いろいろ言ってあげたり
まあ一生懸命苦労する
で 子供もお父さんと一緒になって
まあいろいろ自転車に乗れるように頑張ると
で 自転車に何のことなく乗れるお父さんの心の中では
それは落ち着いているでしょ
困ったり悩んだりとか
そんなこと何もないんだ
自分も知ってるんだから
だから子供は不安定で不安定で
いろんなことを言っても
お父さんは何のことなく
まあいいや まあ乗っちゃいなさいよと
知ってるんです 一回乗っちゃえばもう乗れるんだと
そういう感じで まあいろんなことを言うんだけど
心の中は自分が別に落ち着いている
いつでも乗れるんだから
そういう感じで この知りうる
あの 何といいますか 知らなくてはならないものを知り得たところで
なんか初めて落ち着くというものは心に現れてきます
で 誰もそれ感じたことがないと思いますよ
このほっとしましたと
なんかすごい必死に何かやらなくちゃいけない
すごい仕事をして それ終わったところで
なんかすごい気持ちいいでしょ
終わった瞬間で ほっと
あ やっと終わったと 終わったぞというあの気持ち
あれは最高の気持ちなんです
そこで我々はもう死ぬまで
死んでおごれるまで必死になって走ってるんだけど
終わったぞというこのほっとした気持ちは
瞬間でも味わうことはできません
なぜならば やっていることは違いますから
医学やったり法学やったりするんじゃなくて
これはこの骨の基本的なところの問題だから
生きるということを勉強しなくちゃいけないんですね
そうするとほっとするんです
そういうわけで この私たちにもちょっとした経験がありますから
ほんのちょっとの仕事を乗り越えたところで
ほんのちょっとの問題解決したところで
ものすごい気持ちいいでしょ
何か問題解決しましたと
何かちょっとトラブルがあって
行ってさっさと行って何かしたところでうまくいったと
あるいは自分で何かやりたくて
15 年間も頑張った 頑張ったところで
やっと15年目にうまくいったと
すごい楽しいんです その瞬間で
終わったと 戦いは そこで永久的に生命が持っている
この問題解決したら どれほどほっとするんですかね
ちょっと仕事終わってほっとすることとは違うでしょ
桁外れでしょ 一切の問題解決しましたと
だから仏教では悟りにはこういう言葉使っているんです
これはパラマン・スカンというんです
パラマンというのはラスト最高という意味
この上ない 英語では absolute
ラスト ファイナル absolute という意味で使いるし
パラマン最高なん 絶対的なスカンというのはハピネス
幸福 幸福です ですから
絶対的な最高な この上ない幸福っていうのは悟りなんです
私はそういうすごく このお釈迦様はすごい論理的にこういう言葉を使っていると思っているんです
すごい論理的に まあその通りでしょうとわかるでしょう
人生にあるあるてある一切の問題解決であれば
最高にホッとするでしょうね
私は山の山歩きにしたところで
もう迷子になっちゃって
歩くは歩くは歩くは道路で
もう足も痛いし 足の裏でもう何て言いますか
タコとかいっぱいできたりして
それで膝ももう痛くてとかね
痙攣も落としたりしているところで
ボロ車でもそこら辺通ったところで止まってくれたらホッとするんじゃないんですか
トラクターでもいいでしょうに
そこら辺畑で仕事をしている
あんたなんか歩きそうもないんだけど
どこに行くんですか？って言ったら
まあどこでもいいんだから
この人がいるところに行きたい
じゃあ乗ってくださいと
そういうように 我々は大変苦しんでいる時は
適切な答えが来るとものすごいホッとするんです
ですから すべての問題解決したということで
パラマン・スカン それも悟りのことを表れる表すもう一つの言葉なんです
はい じゃあまあ一応基本的な
まだたくさん言葉がありますが
このパラマン・スカンという言葉は
この本当は行の 4 の 1 なんですけど
この上に使える付け加えなくちゃいけないもう一つの言葉があります
これはニッバーナ・パラマン・スカンなんです
はっきり書くと これはここに繋げるんです
ニッバーナ・パラマン・スカン
ニッバーナというのは皆様よく知っている涅槃ですね
涅槃は絶対的な幸福であると
絶対的な幸せである だから本当はこの悟りという言葉ではなくて
お釈迦様よく使っている言葉っていうのはニッバーナという言葉なんです
そこでなんでニッバーナ涅槃という言葉を使うかと
そこでまた深いわけがあるんです
そこで今まで私はいろんな説明
いろんな説明ではなく
ただ一つの説明しかしてないんだけど
あの生命はいつでも何か探している
どこかへ走っている いろんなことをしている
何かしなくちゃものすごく不安になる
することによっても不安になる
何もしないでいたらすごい苦しみを感じて
何かしなくちゃいけないと
そこで一切の人間が生きる上のすべての行動をしている
政治学も法学もなんだかんだをやりながら
音楽も踊りもいろんなことをやって
我々は生きている で 何でしょうかね
とにかく何かしているんですね
この動物園の動物を観賞したことがあるでしょう
動物園の檻は小さいんだけど
この虎とかキツネとか
それからヤマネコとかね
いるんでしょ そこを見るといつでも歩いているんです
ここ ここから向こうへ行って
向こうからここに来る
またここから向こうへ行って
また向こうからここに来ると
なんか仕事をしているんです
ほんのちょっとでも止まりません
そこで調べるわ いろんなことする
あんな小さな檻ならやることないんだけど
あの檻の中に捕まってる動物は死ぬまであれやってるんです
死ぬまで仕事終わらないんです
そうやって私たちもずっと
何かやってます 何かはやってます
そこでやってるのはいいんです
問題は何かやることないとなんで燃えてくるんですかね
心の中でも危ないんだと
そこを感じたことはありますか？何もやることなくなったと
ものすごい不幸でしょ
その瞬間で やること全部なくなったと
興味を失ったと  興味を失ったといえば
それは別な病気なんですよ
そうではなくて やりたい気持ちはあるんだけど
もういらんと 自分が料理は作りたいんだけど
食べる人はいない でお母さんに料理作るんだから
息子に頼んで あんたご飯食べて
いえ 忙しいんだから外で食べますからという風に出ていくと
旦那さんにあんた何かご飯でも食べて
いえ もう暇がないんだと
外で食べますから あんたらもう楽にしなさいと
最初はもう文句言いながら晩ご飯作っていたお母さんが
あるある時期になってくると
お父さんも外で食べてくるんだからというし
子供たちも要りませんというし
それで ああ 楽だ 晩ご飯作らなくてもいいんだと
今日の献立考えなくてもいいんだということにならないでしょうに
かえってかえって変に怒るんですね
なんであなた方はと 晩ご飯ぐらい家族一緒に食べたらどうですか？と
なんか変でしょ？人間の心っていうのは
そこではい わかりました
我々はみんな晩御飯に毎日来ますよと言って
もう家族みんな来るようになってきたらまた文句を言うんです
すごい文句を言うんです
だから何ですかね 私たちは
そこで理解してほしいのは
もし私たちにはやること何もなくなった場合
...ものすごい苦しみ感じるんです
まあ嫌で嫌で 壁ぶん殴って壁に穴でも作る穴でも作りたくなるぐらい
そこら辺で今まで運動するために
あの手 あの手でなんか鉄でできてる何かあるでしょ？あれ
なんて言いますか 鉄割れ
あれで運動するんじゃなくて
食べたくなるんです 噛んでやりましょう
それぐらいすっごくもう嫌な気持ちになるんです
そういうことで みんなわざとバカなことでもして
自分を忙しくしているんです
わざとなんかもう 例えば時々今やってるかどうか分かりませんだけど
女性の方々はもうやること全然ないんだけど
必死になって編み物してる
編んでるんです セーター編んだり
靴下編んだり あれ着る人はいないんだけど
とにかく真剣に編むと
そういうふうなことをしてなんとか落ち着くんですね
私も一回そうやって真剣真面目に編んだセーター一つもらったことがあります
重く ものすごく重かったんです
だからどんな真剣で編んだかわかりませんでしたけど
一回も着たことはない
捨てましたけど 本人には言ってないんだけど
着てみようと思ったんで
とにかく あんまりにも重いっていうことは
それぐらいもうあれ入って
でもやっぱり丁寧にまあ手作りだからね
あっちこっちやっぱり均等に編んでないし
穴あるところは穴で ものすごくぎゅぎゅぎゅっとされて
それでバランスはないんですね
そこで手を見たら 手はあまりにも重くてボロボロともう伸びちゃうんですね
俺は一回も着られませんと
で こういうことで捨てましたけど
でもこの編んだ人は結構時間かけて
大変苦労して編んだだろうと思います
だから別にそれ捨てたことは無意味じゃないんです
もったいないでもなんでもないんです
そこに意味があるのは
3ヶ月間かけて編んだ
ただそれだけ 終わって次の日はそれはもう燃えないゴミでいいか
燃えるゴミ出してもいいんだから
セーターだからね 燃えるゴミ出せばいいんです
だから私たちは何かやることになってくると
なくなってくると頭が狂ってしまうんです
それだから目的はどうであろうか
意味があろうかなかろうか
とにかく何かやると だから世の中でいらんものばっかりでしょ
例えばスポーツなんかはね
100メートル競争とか
何のためにやってるんですかね
400メートルもう世界記録を出しましたと
あれで何かになるんですかね
あんなこと M NHKの衛星放送局なんか見ると
もう何時間もかけてもうアメリカとか
ゴルフのワールドなんとかなんて言っても
何時間もかけてもうなんか何やってるんですかと
小さな球 何回で穴に落とせるかと
でもそれは冗談じゃないんで
ものすごい能力 ものすごい精神力
もうすっごい必要なんです
だから目的はどうでもいいんです
これ 人類の役に立つか立たないか
どうでもいいんです ただ
それやるだけで もうこの我々心の中で持ってるこのすごいエネルギーを何とかして消す
だからそういうわけで
この昨日か亡くなったんでしょ？原子爆弾研究なんかやってたの
教授が 名前何でしたっけ？あのウラン発見した先生
で すごい人なんです もうアメリカの大統領たちとみんなもう仲良しで
です あの もう 80歳で亡くなったんだけど
一番最後 年取った時の講義を一つテレビで聞いたんだけど
すごい人だと思ったんですけど
もうものすごい頭いいんです
で だから喋るものはもの誰にでもわかります
すごく冗談交じって喋ってるんだから
まあとにかく亡くなったんだけど
ですから 人々にそうやって頭に何かやらなくちゃいけないんだから
この自然界になかった幻想作っちゃうんです
幻想を作るんだから 自然界にもなかった
それでそれをどのように操れるかと
そこまでして で 原子爆弾作って
そこで人を殺してみて
ああ それぐらい殺されるんだと
でも私たちは人を殺されたとか
もうこれはああだこうだと泣いたりするんだけど
やってる側にとってはもう冗談じゃないんで
もっとやらせてくれとということなんです
それすっごく能力使って
飲ます食わすで研究する
実験する そうやって人々はやってることの 99%の仕事は本当は全部いらんもんなんです
ほとんどいらないもんなんです
そこで地球破壊までしているでしょう
それなんでそんないらないものをやってますかというと
これおかしいでしょう
なんでそこまでやってますかというと
あのお母さんの例でわかるでしょうに
晩ご飯作る時は忙しくて本当に困ったもんですねとかね
今晩も今晩は何を作ればいいんですか？とか
もういろいろ苦労してるんだけど
やがて食べれない 食べれなくなったところで
家族がもう大きくなったところでまたかえって文句言うんだから
論理的に考えると 今までお母さんが文句ばっかし言って晩ご飯作ったんだから
今日からお休みと 晩ご飯作らなくてもいいんだと
休んでくださいと言ったら
休めるところかかえって文句を言うと
そんな精神状態は人間にはいつでもあります
だから原子爆弾まで作る
で よく考えてください
スバルというスバルでしたっけ？望遠鏡は
ハワイのスバル  スバル
あれ ものすごい技術でしょ
何年もかけて考えて すごいお金かけて
それからそれなりのプロ中のプロの専門家たちが集めて
そこでもう住み着いて
すごいこうして空見てるんです
何かなるんですかね そこでおかしい
比べてくれるんです 今までの望遠鏡ではここまでしか見えなかったと
これではここまで見えるんだから
ただ空見てるだけですから
でもその裏を考えてください
ただ空を見てるだけなんですけど
あの機械を管理するために
厳密にあの鏡やいろんなものを調整するために
どれぐらいプログラム必要か
どれぐらいの高度なコンピューター必要かと
それにかかるお金とか
それにもう必要な税金とか
それにどれぐらい人間が仕事をしなくちゃいけないかとかね
税金を下げるためにとか
それ全部まとめて 日本国が作ってるんだから日本の税金でしょうし
ですから みんな一生懸命苦労して仕事して
なんとか税金を納めて
それからそれ中で大量なお金を入れて望遠鏡を作って空見てるんです
ですから 人類がやっているこの文化とか科学とかってしてやっていることは
別にみんな聞かない これ役に立つか立たないかと
私にとって この今 宇宙ステーションですか
スペースステーションとか何とかとか
あれよりは子供たちがこのロボットやら恐竜のおもちゃで遊んでるでしょ
あの方がまあ賢いなと思っちゃうんです
あれよりもうなんかバカバカらしく見えるんですね
そこいて何するんですかと
ただ単に自分の技を試してるだけ
この心の中にあるこの止まらないこのエネルギーを
試してるだけ ですから
このポイントに戻りますけど
人間にはやることあると
あ これで忙しいんだからなんとか落ち着いています
なんとかそこでやること早く終わっちゃったら
落ち着きがなくなっちゃうんです
そうすると新しいものを探す
その私たちは この天才やらものすごい頭のいい人やというのは
私たちよりたくさん仕事をできるんだからなんです
ただそれだけのこと そこで私たちは普通の会社に入って
サラリーマンで普通の仕事をすることで人生いっぱいだから
天才にはなりっこはないんですね
それで落ち着いているんです
もし会社に普通のサラリーマンで入ったんだけど
会社の仕事を見たところであまりにも小さくて
自分にしたらもうなんか １日の仕事やと
なんだこれと思ったら
ものすごくつまらなくなっちゃうんですね
仕事がつまらないんだと
もっと大胆なことないかと他のところを探すんです
で そこまで皆様方は自分の経験で理解できると思います
そこで私たちの心の中を見ましょう
心っていうのは燃えているんです
この皆様 日本語で言ってる燃える燃え方じゃないんです
なんかもう燃えてきたぞというのは
なんかやる気が出たぞって意味で使ってるでしょ
そういう意味ではなくて
悪い意味で考えてください
これ燃えてる 焼いてると
だからやることなかったら
この焼いてる火がどうします？その人
そのその人を焼いてしまっちゃうんです
燃やしてしまっちゃうんです
だから人を早くも亡くなってほしいと思うならばね
旦那さんでもいいんですけど
すべてやってあげてください
何もやること何も頼まない
ゴミ箱 ゴミ ゴミでもゴミを捨ててくださいとも頼まないで
はい わかります 私は捨てますと
お茶飲んだらすぐお茶をカップを持っていて
それ洗っておくと 旦那さんが歯を磨こうとした瞬間で行って
さっと歯ブラシに歯磨きを入れてあげる
はい どうぞと で 歯磨き終わったなと思ったら
自分で歯ブラシを取って洗ってあげると
1週間その人死んじゃいます
やることないんだから
いろいろ人にお金払って頼まなくてもいいんです
ですから そこで冗談で言ったんだけど
そちらには心理があるんです
で どういう心理かというと
やることなくなるともう嫌で嫌で嫌で嫌で
そこで自分を燃やそうとするんです
自分自身を 自分だ だから
あまりにも食欲多い人は
いろんなものを食べて食べれたら
食べるものなくなったら自分の手も食べるような感じで
まあそんなことはないんだけど
そんな感じで我々やることなくなっちゃうと
自分を破壊に持っていっちゃうんです
それはどんな生命にもある心の働きなんです
ですから 仏教では人の心はものすごい炎で燃えているんだと
火事 山火事で燃えていると
我々は燃えてない瞬間もないんだと
朝も晩も これ火事も 3種類なんですね
ラーガッピドーサ期もうはっきと書いてますけど
3種類の火で燃えているんだと
ラーガアッギドーサアッギもうアッギ
そのアッギっていうのは火ということで
ラーガ ドーサ モーハっていうのは貪瞋痴ですね
むさぼり 怒り 無知 ラーガアッギっていうのはむさぼりと欲という火
欲の炎 ドーサアッギというのは怒りの炎
もうアッギっていうのは無知の炎
この 3種類の火事で 山火事でもう常に燃えている
ですから もう暑くてもういられないんです
そこでいろんなことで私たちはそれをちょっと紛らわす
何て言いますか ちょっとごまかしちゃうということなんですね
だからこれ同じく火に例えても
例えば自分たち 私たちの周りでずっと火が燃えているんだったら
私たちは暑くてもう生きていられないでしょうね
そこで何か目の前で何か板でもちょっと入れておいて
ちょっとかばして あ ほっとするとそこで
でもこちらからまた燃えてくるんだから
そちらも何かしてせ置くと
そこでこちらにあった板をこちらに持ってきて
こちらで置いておくと
もう大丈夫ですけど そこでどんどんこちらまた暖かくなってくるんで
そこでそちらにまた持っていくと
そうすると前の方がものすごく熱くて
その板を前に持っていったりとか
そうやって自分のこの燃える熱さをなんとかなんとかしているんであって
終わりがないんですね
そうすると考えるのは
じゃあ全面的に体何かで燃えない
何か服であの覆った方がいいんじゃないかと
ああ それは良かったと思って
何かもらったとする そうすると体は燃えない
何か服で体隠しちゃいますけど
周りはずっと燃えているんだから
5 6分経つと中で暑くてもいられない
で またそれを開けたりする
であ もう熱いと その熱いと言ったところで
また外からまた燃えてくるんだから
またその中で隠れたりする
そうやって人生なんですね
心の中で この 3種類の火がずっと燃えているんだから
まあ歌でも歌ったり カラオケでも歌ったり
美味しいものを食べたり
仕事をしたり あのいろんな人々と友達を作って喋ったりとかね
電話で誰かと喋ったりとか
そこで散歩に行ったりして
なんとか 24時間はなんとかします
次の日も朝も朝だから朝ごはん食べなくちゃいけない
朝の運動しなくちゃいけないんですから
それでまあそういうことをして
それから掃除やら全部終わって
それから新聞でも読みましょうと
テレビでも見ましょうと
あるいはちょっと買い物で行こうとか
なんとかして 24時間忙しく
忙しくしているんです
そこで死ぬまでやっているんです
それだけの人生なんですよ
だからあそこで何の意味もないんですよ
昨日亡くなった偉い教授にしても
皆様にしても みんな同じなんですよ
この 24時間なんとかするだけなんです
たまたまあの人にはいっぱいできただけ
仕事 私たちには会社の仕事でもう疲れただけのことでね
そうやって 24時間なんとかしてごまかしてはいる
そこでポイントは 私たちはものすごく燃えているということなんです
それでお釈迦様が考えたのは
この火を消したらどうですかと
火を消すべきですよということは皆様わかっているはずなんです
何もしないで テレビも見ないで
1 日だけでいいんです
自分の部屋でいてみてください
掃除もしないで 料理もしないで
食べなくちゃいけないんだから
もう前の日食べるものは置いといて
せんべいでもいいし 果物でもいいし
料理しないで食べるもの
ビスケットとか あるいはバランスダイエットとかいろいろありますからね
そういうものをいくらか置いといて
それ食べて 24時間自分の部屋でいてみてください
いて楽しいか苦しいかとチェックしてください
部屋の掃除はしません
部屋の整理もしません
電話はかけません テレビも見ません
ラジオも聞きません 料理もしません
ただいるだけ 眠くなったら寝ても構いません
お腹が空いたらこのダイエットのビスケットみたいな
あるでしょ その方が一番便利で簡単だから
せんべい食べるよりは
そのカロリーメイトのビスケットを一つ二つ食べて
それでまたじっといると
24時間楽しいかないかと
別に健康には悪くないと思いますからね
なぜならば ちゃんと寝る時は寝ますからね
寝たい時は もしそういう実験して
まあ自殺したいぐらい苦しいやと言うんだったら
悟り見込みがあるんです
平気で寝たんだったらもう見込みはないんです
まあ別にどうってことない
よく休んだと言ったならば見込みはないんですけどね
ですから そこで私は何を言いたがっているかというと
私たちの心の中でいかに我々は苦しみで燃えているかということなんです
何かやらなくちゃ落ち着かない
じっとしていられない
このすごい恐ろしいエネルギー
原子爆弾を作るエネルギーなんです
ただ 星を見るために あれぐらい技術能力
空を見るために採算かかる
そのエネルギー そこでお釈迦様が言うのは
このそのエネルギーが消えたら
この火が消えたら究極的に落ち着くんだ
ですから この火が消えたという意味でニッバーナと呼ぶんです
ニッバーナの意味は消しましたという意味
消えましたという意味なんです
で 一般的な仏教の世界では
なんか悲観的に見るんです
そういう言葉なんかは
なんか全部消えるんですかね
ああ 悲しいと そういう意味じゃないんです
すごい肯定的な言葉なんです
この私たちは 1 秒たりとも休むことなくずっと感じている
この苦しみの炎 消えちゃうんです
そこでずっとなんか不思議なすすけさが体中ずっとあるんです
あ もうこれで終わりと
そうやってなんか 全ての存在を乗り越えている生命の
もうこの世の中で最高たる幸福なんです
それに勝る幸福は全くありません
そこから見れば 他のものは幸福ではなくて
ただ苦しみの バージョン違いだけなんです
他のものはすべて苦しみなんです
私たちはものすごい勘違いしているんです
若くて若いんだったら楽しいと
健康だったら楽しいと
お金があったら楽しいと
で 仕事があったら楽しいと
あれはちょっと勘違いなんですね
あれは楽しいと なぜ言うかと
仕事がなかったら苦しいんだからなんです
だからあのセーター編むことと同じなんです
やることなんもないし
セーター編んだっても役に立ちませんだけど
とにかくやると  年を取っている男性の方々も
もうかなり写真家がいるんでしょ？で
アマチュアですごくいい機械いっぱい買ってきて
あっちこっち行っていろんなところで写真を撮る
で それ男性の楽しみでも仕事もありません
やることもないんだ あんな写真撮ったって
みんな 1箇所に行ってもう話し合って
その日はこの太陽はこの時間でこうこうやって昇るんだから
こここういう角度で写真撮った方がいいやと思って
みんなもう専門家みたいな感じで
どうせ勉強するんだから
男性だからいろんな研究するんだから
そういう写真を撮る 撮って
もう現像したり お金もなくなりますけど
別にあの写真役に立ちますかね
役に立ちませんよ で 写真の仕事をして生活する人々はまた別にいますからね
そういう人々は別に仕事として写真ごと生活しているしね
このおじいちゃんたちが趣味でやっている写真というのは
まあ才能ある人々はそれなりに展示会やったり
売ったりはしますけど
でもみんなその気持ちはないんです
売る気持ちでやっているわけじゃなくて
お金儲かる気持ちでやっているわけじゃなくて
趣味でやっているんです
だから そういうふうな感じで
私たちはこの苦しみを何とかするために何とかしているだけで
そこは幸せだ 幸福だと思うのは計算違いじゃないかなと
ですから この人生という船は
浸水敷も敷もできないほどボロボロガタガタなんですね
やっと浸水敷やったところで
船はどんどんどんどん沈んでいっちゃうんですね
そこで焦って何とかしよう
何とかしようと困っているだけで
前に進むどころか 必死で頑張って
やがて疲れ果てたところで船は沈んじゃうと
だからお釈迦様は言うのは
この人生という船がもう水に入れることさえもできないんだと
だから威張ってみんな浸水好きやってるんです
やったところで ゾロゾロゾロゾロと船が沈みかけているんですね
そこで作った人々は一生懸命何とかして
これ浮いておこうと 前に進むところまではいかない
だから人々はみんな生まれて年取って死ぬ
それで終わっちゃうんです
何もやってないんです
そうやって過去も現在も未来も
人々は生まれて大きくなって死ぬだけで精一杯
そこでもう進む道はお釈迦様がおっしゃっているこの道なんですね
進んでみようと 進むためにはもう溺れない
沈まない船を 人生という船を作らなくちゃいけない
設計しなくちゃいけない
で そういうことで この私たち幸福というものは
ほんのちょっと一時的な痛み止めだけ
体中がんが入ってきて
いろんなところ痛いんだと
そこで足が痛いと言ったら
足に痛み止めを打つ どうですか？もう痛くはない
よかったよかったと そこで肩の方も痛くなって
じゃあそちらも注射打ちますよと
で 肩に注射を打つ そこでどうですか？あ
痛くないんだと でもそこでその人を幸せと言えますかね？治療したと言えますか？言えません
あまりにも痛いんだから
注射を打ってもらうだけであって
結局は死んでしまっちゃう
そういうことで 我々はお金が最高の幸せだと思って金持ちになりますけど
金持ちも貧乏も同じく死んじゃうんです
病院に行ったら お医者さんにとっては金持ちか貧乏かということは全然関係ないんです
肺が動いているかと心臓はどうで
血圧はどうだ それだけ
だからなんかもったいないでしょうね
一生懸命苦労して金持ちになったっても
で そういうことで たとえ世界一有名な歌う人であったにしたっても
病気になっちゃったらただの人間扱いするでしょ
医者が 私は世界一大スターだよと
ということは全然薬には関係ないんです
そういうことを考えて
私たちはこの一時的にやっている
この子供遊び おもちゃ遊び
おもちゃ遊びはみんなやってます
子供から大人まで で そこだけにしてはいけませんと
もうちょっと考えて 究極的な最終的な幸福を探しましょうという
この世の中で誰も言ってない教え
真理の教えはお釈迦様のこの悟りの教えなんです
この悟り 今まで説明したような内容の悟りっていうのは
まあ他の宗教ではほんのちょっと比較研究したことがありますから
見当たらないんです で
今日のお話はそこら辺に終了します
で また質問とかあったら
あるいはもう続けて聞きたければまた続けてお話をしますけど
では どうもありがとうございます